it's the dawn of a new era at the
southern border with the end of title
42. tens of thousands of migrants now
getting the green light to cross into
the U.S without restrictions that had
been in place for three years now
communities both near and far from the
border are declaring states of emergency
but malusion live in Brownsville Texas
how does it look this morning Bill
well Dana I can tell you we were out
here at midnight as title 42 finally
expired though we never saw a large Rush
of migrants now it's daylight and we are
waiting to see what the Day brings take
a look at this video last night we were
with a group of four Republican Senators
as they received a tour of the area here
in Brownsville from the border patrol
Union they took us down to the main
Crossing area where we have seen
thousands of people crossing in recent
days that area has now effectively been
sealed off by the Texas National Guard
with all sorts of razor wire and we were
with all of these Senators as title 42
dropped at midnight again we did not see
a huge expected Rush what we did see was
all the migrant camps across the river
with all the migrants in them with
campfires going and music playing from
across the river here's what Senator Ted
Cruz had to tell me
they're 22 000 illegal immigrants right
on the other side Matamoras they have
fires going they've had music going
they're partying because in a couple of
hours title 42 is ending and all 22 000
are going to invade this country
and Joe Biden and Kamala Harris will be
the last Mile in the human trafficking
Network and take them to every city in
America
now again that huge predicted Rush has
not yet materialized but that doesn't
mean it's not going to happen at some
point there are still migrants thousands
of them in Mexico who have been
Gathering there this is what we saw last
night we sent a photographer over to
matamotos migrants looked like they
wanted to cross but this is what they
saw across the river Texas National
Guard barbed wire they're on a megaphone
telling them not to cross we saw one guy
get in the water and make an attempt but
it was essentially a standoff all night
you see one guy finally makes it over
but Texas has taken a new posture they
are blocking people and they are not
letting people in and the migrants were
chanting and again we just did not see a
large Rush last night but there is a
possibility it's going to happen here's
why take a look at this last piece of
video migrant shelters across Mexican
border cities are still completely at
capacity with migrants who have shown up
there are tens of thousands of migrants
in Mexico border cities who are still
waiting they're essentially in a holding
pattern right now title 42 is gone and
now it appears these migrants are
waiting deciding what they want to do
next so we're just going to be keeping
an eye out on that and back out here
live a major decision taking place last
night late last night a federal judge in
Florida blocked the Biden Administration
from being able to do their Mass parole
releases of migrants a parole release
means they do not get a court date they
are instead asked to turn themselves
into ice within 60 days the Biden
administration had argued in court and
said we need this policy if we can't
have it we're going to have 45 000
people in custody by the end of the
month disease could spread because of
over capacity issues and there would be
quote catastrophic consequences well the
federal judge came back and said nope
you can't do it this is largely a
problem of your own making we'll send it
back to you Bill can I ask you yesterday
secretary Majorca said something that he
has said repeatedly but it took on I
think an additional significance as he
said it yesterday listen here
I want to be very clear
our borders are not open people who
cross our border unlawfully and without
a legal basis to remain will be promptly
processed and removed
the cartels listen to a message like
that like how do they react
well look they they what they tell the
migrants is if you get here you have a
very good chance of being released and
when secretary mayorka says that if you
cross illegally you will be processed
and quickly removed you have to put an
asterisk next to that that is the case
for some people but right now a majority
of people are released into the country
what happens is because they're so over
capacity and because of diplomatic
relations with different countries once
people get here they're typically
released with an NTA a future court date
and because of how backlogged everything
is that court date can be years down the
road and the cartels are able to
advertise off of that the migrants know
that they've they told us that in
interviews that if they can just get
here they believe they are going to be
released and if you just walk to
downtown Brownsville right now you'll go
to the bus station and you will see
Venezuelan men with their ntas and their
DHS packets and their government cell
phones all over the place waiting to get
on a bus to go elsewhere around the
country Mass releases are taking place
and it is part of the Biden
administration's policy you are several
hundred miles away from Yuma Arizona
they did it yesterday for the first time
in two years in that town now in
Brownsville where you're located that
that's where they put the concertina
wire up this week that's where Governor
Abner ordered a lot of other officers to
respond along that River it seemed to
have stopped some of that flow
has it
yeah yeah they've essentially plugged it
up the first few days I was here this
week I mean you guys saw the drone
images we were putting up it was a
free-for-all down here at this spot
lines of several hundred people just
crossing at will with zero resistance
whatsoever then a couple of days ago
that specialized Texas National Guard
response for showed up with riot gear
and all sorts of razor wire and they
changed their posture they are blocking
people from entering now we'd never seen
them do that before and these migrants
are coming across expecting to be let in
and instead they're greeted by rows of
razor wire and Troopers standing there
with their arms crossed saying no you're
not coming in so now they're likely
going to have to try to find another
area to cross in those cartels and
smuggling organizations are going to
have to take a minute to figure out how
how to approach this are they going to
find somewhere else to go Texas only has
a limited amount of resources but it
just goes to show the difference in
posture between the state of Texas
actively blocking people and the federal
government which sent troops down here
essentially to do paperwork wow
film illusion I'm sure we'll see you
more this afternoon thank you Bill thank
you I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade
and I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis